there's a pretty good piece in Washington
monthly by David Athens, which reminds us
that for all of the bad that's taking place
in the United States right now, it's important
not to lose sight of what's just the [inaudible]
full
reality that 20 Republicans in the Senate
could end the national nightmare that is Donald
Trump and I would actually go even further,
14 Republicans could remove Donald Trump.
We talk about Trump as this national disease,
this virus that has infected tens of millions
of people with seemingly overwhelming numbers
necessary to remove of in the November, November
of 2020 election, will we need 62 million
votes?
Will we need 64 well, we need 70 million votes
depending on which States those votes come
in to remove Donald Trump.
There are actually some tiny groups of people
that could remove the president if they had
a backbone, if they decided that they were
going to do the right thing rather than the
partisan thing.
So let's first start with David Atkins piece.
David Atkins piece reminds us that quote,
the most accountable people in America now
are the Craven Republican elected officials
who have the power to stop this yet refuse
to, and Atkins goes on to say, all it would
take is 20 Republican senators to say no to
say that enough is enough to put the interests
of the United States ahead of their temporary
partisan interests.
It would only take well under half of the
Republican Senate caucus to do the right thing
and Atkins points out.
This wouldn't even be that bad for the Republican
party.
In the end, you get Mike Pence, right?
It would even cost them.
It wouldn't even cost them that much as a
party.
He writes, Democrats are extremely unlikely
to lose the house in 2020 hence the large
number of Republican retirements.
The Senate is likely to be deadlocked.
Getting rid of Trump would still leave Mike
Pence in the white house with the ability
to nominate extremist Federalist society.
Judges David Atkins is completely right, but
it's actually even worse.
It's not just 20 Republicans in the Senate.
There is an even smaller group that we could
remove Donald Trump because under the 25th
amendment, just 14 people could remove a sitting
president.
The 25th amendment outlines a process for
removing a president who is either unable
or unfit to serve.
Section four of the 25th amendment allows
the vice president and a majority of the cabinet
to remove the president from office.
Under that fourth section, it would take 14
people to remove Donald Trump, vice president
Mike Pence, and 13 of the 24 cabinet members.
Section four reads, we'll put it up on the
screen whenever the vice president and a majority
of either the principle officers of the executive
departments or of such other body as Congress
may by law provide transmit to the president
pro tempore of the Senate and the speaker
of the house of representatives, their written
declaration that the president is unable to
discharge the powers and duties of his office.
The vice president shall immediately assume
the powers and duties of the office as acting
president.
This is a very quick and simple process in
a sense.
Consider the immorality of being able to end
this national nightmare among a group of just
20 Republicans in the Senate among a group
of 14 Republicans in the cabinet, including
Mike Pence and choosing not to do it.
This is the virus of political partisanship
and cronyism that we've been talking about.
We'll w I talked earlier in the show.
We just need for Republicans to say, let's
subpoena John Bolton for Republicans in the
Senate and then we can do it.
That gets us a simple majority.
We will be hard pressed to find four Republican
senators who are willing just to do the very
milk toast uncontroversial thing of subpoenaing
John Bolton to testify in Donald Trump's impeachment
trial.
Forget about 14 Republicans in the cabinet
or 20 Republicans in the Senate, but my bet
if I were to bet is they go down with the
ship or try to outlast this.
There is zero indication that any of these
people want to be a part of the solution or
that they even really agree about what the
solution is.
Good luck finding 20 Republicans with a conscience,
let alone Republican senators.
You would have better luck getting a Santa
the tooth fairy and the Easter bunny to remove
Donald Trump in 2020 than you would finding
20 Republican senators or 14 Republican cabinet
members to make it a reality.
We're going to have to do it without them
and I can, you know it when I said this a
year and a half ago, it felt like maybe it
wasn't the case.
A year and a half ago.
I was saying, Trump clearly should be impeached.
Trump clearly should be removed under the
25th amendment.
Something seems cognitively wrong.
Uh, something is very wrong in terms of the
degree of corruption that this guy is participating
in.
But a year and a half ago I was saying, I
still believe the Mueller report isn't going
to do it.
Impeachment isn't going to do it.
November of 2020 is very quickly going to
become the first soonest and best opportunity
to remove the guy.
We're now only just under, you know, 10 10
months minus a week away from the November
of 2020 election.
It is becoming clearer and clearer that that
is the quickest, most efficient and most direct
way to remove the guy.
I hope we recognize that.
I hope we don't allow the activism that so
many people have participated in since Donald
Trump was first elected to kind of fade and
the enthusiasm to Wayne.
We've got to remember the opportunity is coming
up.
It's less than 10 months away.